Let's get back to what we still call the phone
lines, although they're really at this point, just
Internet bits. We do take calls via discord. You
can find our discord at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord. Let's go next to James from
New York City. You're on the air.
Hi, wow. It's the first time I came
on the discovery, so thank you.
I was just wondering, there may be
a slight lead up to my question, but
I want to talk about the New York senatorial race
in New York City, OK? Because currently half of
the voters are undecided at this point. So it's
kind of just open. Obviously, we've got Yang.
Now, hold on a second. You're saying
mayoral race because you said senatorial.
Oh, sorry. Mary, Mary. OK, good, good, good. Yeah.
And even recently, the chief of the division of
thoracic surgery at Mount Sinai, Roger
Floras, went into the race. So it's just
kind of all out in the open. I just I guess
my question would be, who is from what you
seen your preferred candidate, if you have one?
And how do you feel about the race in general?
Listen, I'm not really taking a position on it
because I've not examined all of the candidates.
Obviously, Andrew Yang has been a guest on
this program. I think he has great ideas.
You know, one of the critiques of Yang as a
presidential candidate, I think serves him well
in theory as mayor, which is that he's more of
like a project management guy where he sees a
lot of political issues as we just kind of need to
take a consultancy approach, a kind of technocrat.
And New York City mayor is one of those
things where you're going to have a bunch
of people hating you no matter what you do,
and someone like Yang who's just going to sort
of come in and take this project management
approach and be guided hopefully by data. And
I'm idealizing here, but like ignore the sort of
hyperbole around the fringes. He might be quite
well suited to the job. Now, I know that there
are people who will say, you know, he's really
lived upstate, like he has this place in the
city. He's not really a New York City resident.
OK, you know, fine. Like we can we can debate all
that stuff. But I think some of what made him less
appealing as a presidential candidate makes him
potentially better suited as New York City mayor.
Yeah, it was just a really interesting
political move when I saw that, you know.
Yes. Well, are you supporting him?
I'm not sure yet, I think I'll just kind of
wait to see how things go, because, again,
I think I'm kind of in the majority of the
people are undecided at this point. OK, OK.
Yeah, I mean, I thought he was leading. I
thought he was leading the primary, but I
haven't seen it in like twenty eight percent of
the vote or something. Oh I see. He's not he has
a plurality but not at this point. Well listen, if
there's 10 candidates, you don't need a majority.
Oh, of course. You know, people would
drop out. Sure. It's relatively.
All right, very good, James.
We'll follow the race for sure.
James. All right, James has done very
good. Yeah, that's an interesting race